bonjour à
tous donc un petit point d'agenda pour
commencer euh aujourd'hui sur toute la
journée nous avons une réunion dans
cette maison de tous les secrétaires
départementaux des républicains avec à
midi un moment d'échange entre Nicolas
Sarkozi et les secrétaires
départementaux
euh mercredi à 14h euh pardon à 11h
Nicolas Sarkozi recevra des syndicats de
policiers et à 12h30 il déjeunera avec
des organisation
syndical de médecins généralistes
euh l'après-midi meeting de Nicolas
Sarkozi à limoge pour soutenir Virginie
camels en présence d'Alain jupet et à
19h nous onons dans cette maison les
rendez-vous du projet donc à
l'initiative d' sur le thème de l'école
au cœur de l'intégration républicaine
qui sera animé par Annie Genevard Nadia
amour et Olivier marlex
ensuite jeudi 15 octobre à 12h30 Nicolas
Sarkozi participera à Bruxelles au
sommet du
PPE alors très bonne nouvelle pour les
républicains nouvelle qui prouve que
l'alternance est belelle et bien en
marche à apte dans le vooclus euh il y a
Dominique Santori a gagné dès le premier
tour la municipale avec un score de 51,4
% et plus de 11 points par rapport à
mars 2014 donc c'est une belle victoire
que nous tenons à saluer il faut noter
que le Front national perd 5 points lors
de cette élection le Front National est
systématiquement en recul depuis le
printemps euh nous l'avons vu avec la
municipale de Clichy d'ère et de Noisy
le Grand récemment donc voilà le il y a
un véritaable progrès constant de la
part des républiains depuis le printemps
un recul du PS pour ne pas dire un
effritement des résultats du PS et un
véritable recul du Front national les
républicains sont bel et bien le seul
rempart contre le Front National et ces
résultats contredisent évidemment tous
les sondages qui donnent le front
national victorieux systématiquement à
chaque élection rappelez-vous des
départementales le résultat a été
qu'aucun département n'est tombé dans
les mains du Front national nous aurons
ces mêmes résultats pour les régionales
puisque nous sommes tous mobilisés
derrière nos candidats pour les
régionales et la victoire sera au
rendez-vous nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir pour ce point presse
Isabelle le calenek et éc vert qui sont
délégués généraux des républicains en
charge du projet pour évoquer euh tout
d'abord un petit point sur le budget que
nous propose euh le gouvernement
socialiste ainsi que la plateforme
contributive mise en place par les
républicains je leur cède tout de suite
la
parole merci Sébastien juste un mot sur
le le budget parce que c'est une semaine
budgétaire qui commence au Parlement on
est dans un un budget qui était
extraordinairement vide enfin je sais
pas si on est seul dans l'univers mais
il y a un vide sidéral sur le budget et
qui est absolument considérable il y a
aucune réponse aux vraies questions qui
se pose sur les 18 prochains mois
monsieur Holland n'a pas terminé son
mandat donc il devrait y avoir une
feuille de route qui se traduisent par
évidemment des inscriptions budgétaires
et c'est pas le cas la baisse des impôts
l'impôt sur le revenu est une baisse
assez en en en
en une c'est une baisse qui qui qui ne
correspond pas à l'ensemble des
contribuables puisqueune grande partie
des contribuables français seront
augmentés que la la la la dimension de
l'impôt sur le revenu 70 milliards se
concentre de plus en plus sur de moins
en moins de contribuables et donc il a
une augmentation très forte mais à des
niveau de revenus qui ne sont pas DV
niveau de d'hyper riche quand vous avez
4000 € quand vous êtes un couple avec
deux enfants personne ne peut dire que
ce sont des gens qui sont des riches et
ce niveau-là de revenus va au contraire
plutôt participer à une augmentation de
de l'impôt sur le revenu qui reste
d'ailleurs stable l'imposition générale
les prélèvementes obligatoires restent
stable par rapport au au PIB donc il y a
pas de baisse d'impôt alors il y a aussi
une vraie question chez les socialistes
en ce qui concerne l'impôt sur le revenu
ce matin ou ce weekend monsieur monsieur
HRO l'ancien Premier ministre indique
que il veut relancer l'idée d'une fusion
entre le l'impôt sur le revenu et la et
la
CAG il y a 130 parlementaires qui si la
presse dit juste on ont signé son cet
amendement c'est évidemment tout à fait
considérable
il faut bien voir que cette fusion entre
l'impôt sur le revenu et la CAG fusion
sur laquelle nous sommes absolument
opposés à cela correspond à une une
progressivité de la CAG qui touchera là
aussi de plein fouet toutes les
catégories moyennes de de français donc
là il y a évidemment matière à
discussion et opposition de notre de
notre part dénoncer une
baisse fausse baisse de l'impôt sur le
revenu pour beaucoup de de français
dénoncer l'absence de réduction des
dépenses de manière sérieuse dénoncer
l'absence de réduction des déficits
quand on baisse le déficit de 0,5 points
entre 2015 et 2016 et qu'on a baissé que
de 01 point entre 2014 et 2015 on se
pose évidemment des questions sur la
réalité de cette baisse de 0,5 points
qui est très faible par rapport à ce que
font d'autres d'autres pays enfin bref
aucun objectif n'est n'est atteint il y
a aucune proposition dans ce budget pour
permettre d'atteindre les seuls
objectifs qui compte c'est-à-dire la
relance économique du
du du du pays et puis on voit la dette
augmenter systématiquement cette dette
qui commence à plomber et à être un
danger potentiel tout à fait
considérable pour la France cette dette
on continue de laavir augmenter je note
quand même aussi une inquiétude forte
des élus je sais pas si mes collègues
partagent cette inquiétude je pense que
oui très forte des élus la réforme de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement de la
DGF voulu par les les socialistes
contient beaucoup beaucoup d'injustice à
l'intérieur de cette de cette réforme
beaucoup de villes petites ou moyennes
vont voir encore plus baisser leur
dotation qu'elles ne le devaient le le
voir je note d'ailleurs que des grandes
villes vont également souffrir d'une
baisse de de dotation supplémentaire par
rapport déjà la la baisse intégré dans
le le budget je note que Nant en fait
partie mais je note aussi que le
ministre du Budget ou le secrétaire
d'État au budget a indiqué que
évidemment la ville de Nantes sera
récompensé par un autre fond ce qui
m'étonne un peu enfin je n pas vraiment
regarder qui était maire de Nantes mais
je je suis un peu surpris cette façon de
gérer les finances publiques le deuxème
point c'est que nous voulions vous
parler de de faire un point sur ce qui
se passe dans le domaine du du projet on
on travaille beaucoup avec avec Isabelle
et puis l'ensemble des des personnes qui
animent le projet il y a aujourd'hui une
machine vraiment qui est lancée à
l'intérieur des républicains pour
produire produire des idées produire des
débats produire des des contributions
d'abord beaucoup de groupes de travail
ce qui est assez naturel se se
réunissent et nous avons fait un
séminaire à la fois la semaine prochaine
et cette semaine donc sur sur deux
semaines où tous les groupes de travail
il y en a une quinzaine se réunissent le
soir pour soit faire un point soit se
lancer soit aboutir à des conclusions
donc on est dans une un temps
d'accélération de la confection de notre
de notre projet on a beaucoup de groupes
peut évidemment répondre à vos questions
sur la nature de ces de ces groupes qui
vont de l'environnement à la fonction
publique en passant par la sécurité
intérieure donc il y a beaucoup de
groupes il y a aussi un groupe qui
s'occupe plus particulièrement du
franco-allemand comment essayer de de
bien faire converger nos nos politiques
ou diverger mais enfin en tout cas de
faire un point sur ce qu'on peut dire
ensemble et nous nous rendrons bientôt
en Allemagne à l'invitation de la CDU
csou nous avons également la deuxième
volonté c'est de faire participer les
citoyens à la confection de ce de ce
projet et là on a une batterie d'outils
qui ont été mis en place et qui ne sont
plus uniquement des intentions mais qui
sont des réalisations je pense
évidemment
l'application bien connue de de direct
citoyen avec des questionnements
adressés aux Français qui sera bientôt
accessible sur Internet enfin sur des
ordinateurs et pas uniquement sur des
sur des mobiles mais je pense aussi au
fond à à l'ensemble de cette chaîne de
construction d'un projet vous êtes vous
savez maintenant que l'on fait voter
après chaque après chaque convention il
y a eu deux convention sur l'immigration
et sur le code du travail et à chaque
fois environ 50000 personnes 53000 à la
première 42000 à la seconde ont répondu
au au questionnaires que nous avons
édité donc ça c'est très très important
que nos proposition soi validé par les
militants qui souhaitent prendre la
parole mais à l'autre bout de la chaîne
c'està-dire au début de la chaîne nous
venons de mettre en place là c'est ces
jours derniers une plateforme de
contribution on pourra lui trouver un
nom une plateforme de de contribution où
chaque Français peut en venant sur le
site des républicains déposer sa
contribution sur un sujet il y a des
onglets environnement et économie
fiscalité enfin on a toute une série de
de sujets il faut suffit que vous alliez
sur le site et que vous cliquiez sur
projet et là beaucoup de contributions
sont déjà en ligne on en a plus de plus
de 800 alors elles sont pas encore en
ligne il y en a plus de 800 elles sont
évidemment regarder lu par un certain
nombre de de rapporteurs d'ailleurs des
des groupes de travail et elles
viendront appuyer les propositions que
nous faisons c'est très important de
pouvoir dire à tous les Français là ça
s'adresse à tout le monde à tous les
Français si vous voulez contribuer à un
projet d'alternance vous pouvez faire
des propositions et ces propositions
elles sont centralisées Isabelle vous le
dira mieux que je je ne saurais le dire
donc on va au fond du début c'estàd
poster des contributions jusqu'à la fin
qui est voté à un moment donné là ce
sont les militants c'est normal sont des
adhérents votés sur les propositions que
l'on fait au travers des des conventions
et puis on a également donc sur ces
conventions nous en avons fait deux
comme je l'ai dit on en a trois en
préparation donc il y a un travail
très important sur ces trois conventions
à venir le 3 novembre sur la sécurité le
18 novembre sur l'agriculture et la
ruralité et le 25 novembre sur la
fonction publique ces sujets étant
évidemment des sujets extrêmement
importants au cœur de de beaucoup de
préoccupations de nos concitoyens je
pense par exemple à la fonction publique
Nicolas Sarkozi a abordé ce sujet dans
son interview aux écho il y a une
quinzaine de jours et nous allons
creuser puissamment l'idée que comment
comment rénover refonder puisque c'est
le terme aujourd'hui qu'il faut employer
la manière de servir des des
fonctionnaires il y a pas une vision
négative il y aura au contraire une
vision positive de la fonction publique
mais en même temps évidemment une vision
de changement de cela d'ailleurs on ne
peut pas avoir des remarques sur le code
du travail on peut pas avoir fait un
travail approfondi comme nous l'avons
fait sur le code du travail et ne pas
faire le même travail sur son pendant
c'est-à-dire au fond le statut de la
fonction publique mais aussi la manière
de rémunérer la manière d'être la
responsabilisation des des des des
fonctionnaires donc ces trois sujets
sont évidemment très importants et puis
à côté de ces conventions sont en
général des demi-journées qui sont
conclusives les républicains donneent un
certain nombre de conclusions plus que
des pistes c'est des des solutions que
nous proposons vous l'avez bien vu
beaucoup de débats se sont faits au
moment de de notre convention sur
l'immigration tout cela a tourné autour
des propositions que nous faisions et ça
a été le cas aussi dans le domaine du
code du du du travail nous allons euh
aussi organiser des nous continuons à
organiser en marche de ces conventions
des des rendez-vous on appelle ça les
rendez-vous du projet qui ne sont pas
conclusifes qui sont des débats de
simples débats mais qui nous permettent
de préparer ces conventions il y a eu un
débat très intéressant la semaine
dernière sur l'économie sur Lefin la
santé et le numérique animé notamment
par Arnaud Robinet qui est notre un des
secrétaires nationaux chargés de la de
la santé et nous en avons d'autres en
préparation euh nous avons B comme l'a
dit d'ailleurs Sébastien l'école au cœur
de l'intégration républicaine le 14
octobre nous aurons quelque chose sur le
modèle social le 4 novembre avec Claude
Greff quelque chose sur les OPEC
c'està-dire les opérations extérieures
militaire donc dans le domaine de la
défense organisé par Philippe Menier le
18 novembre et puis le 2 décembre
Yannick Morau organise quelque chose sur
la la mer est-elle l'avenir de la terre
la mer mer bien sûr donc on rentre dans
les sujets écologiques que nous
traiterons au fur et à mesure du temps
donc on est en ordre de bataille en
ordre de marche euh il y a beaucoup de
de travail qui est réalisé c'est un
travail de fond je pense et j'espère en
tout cas que c'est un travail sérieux
euh voilà ce que je souhaitais vous dire
pour faire un point sur l'état
d'avancement du projet
oui merci Éric je vais juste apporter
quelques précisions par rapport à à ce
que tu viens de dire les groupes de
travail il y en a 19 euh donc c'est euh
beaucoup de contributions des uns et des
autres avec Éric on va euh ensemble voir
comment les choses avancent et on a
également des groupes de travail qui se
constittu auprès de ce qu'on appelle les
fédérations professionnelles et notre
rôle à Éric et moi c'est aussi de faire
en sorte que il y ait des contributions
croisé de la part des fédérations
professionnelles et bien évidemment des
groupes de travail thématiques sur
Direct citoyen parce que la question
nous est souvent posée il y a à peu près
20000 personnes qui répondent
régulièrement aux questions qui sont
donc posé sur Direct citoyen c'est une
application qu'on peut avoir sur notre
portable on est régulièrement informé
des nouvelles questions qui arrive et
c'est très facile de se prononcer mais
alors c'est souvent binaire c'est par
oui ou par non c'est pour ça qu'on a
souhaité en effet créer une application
dont vient de parler Éric de
contribution où les gens peuvent aller
davantage dans le détail et faire leurs
propositions donc je voulais juste vous
montrer euh en illustration ce que ce
que ce que vient de dire éic tu peut
m'aider et me tenir peut-être ça Lydia
merci donc vous allez sur le site des
républicains on ouvre largement et pas
seulement donc aux adhérents les
républicains notre idée non mais je vais
vous montrer notre idée c'est vraiment
que tous les Français qui le souhaitent
et il y a une soif de participer
aujourd'hui puissent déposer leurs
contribution donc vous allez sur le site
des reppublicain.fr on met le projet au
au centre au cœur vous avez donc
l'onglet projet vous mettez je participe
et là vous avez une case pour mettre je
participe donc participer vous créerz
votre compte c'est très simple à faire
avec votre adresse mail et un mot de
passe et vous avez les contributions qui
viennent d'être déposées donc comme
venez de de le dire Erric on aura sans
doute d'ici la fin de la semaine à peu
près un millier de de contributions on
les modère bien évidemment et euh quand
vous cliquez sur contribution euh donc
là on est à faire une proposition voilà
on a par exemple déjà euh sur le temps
de travail une première contribution euh
une personne qui a voulu s'exprimer sur
l'allocation de libre choix euh une
autre sur les gains de productivité dans
les entreprises une autre sur le dossier
médical euh personnalisé et cetera et
cetera donc vous avez une rentré par 19
thématiques qui ressemblent grosso modo
à nos 19 groupes de travail et vous
pouvez mais de façon très très très
simple déposer votre contribution et ce
sera une matière première qu'on ajoutera
à tout ce qui est fait dans les groupes
de travail tout ce qui est fait dans nos
réunions de de de de travail et bien
évidemment dans les rendez-vous du
projet comme le disait Éric l'intérêt
des Rendez-vous du projet toutes les
semaines ici c'est d'élargir le cercle
audelà des républicains et d'avoir un
vrai débat à l'inverse des réunions de
style convention qui sont toujours
conclu par le le le président Nicolas
Sarkozi où il y a des tables rondes où
c'est exclusivement les personnes qui
sont invitées au tables rondes qui
s'expriment dans les rendez-vous du
projet nos propos sont très liminires et
ensuite la parole est à la salle et
c'estes questionsréponses voilà une
grande formation politique comme la
nôtre c'està-dire le premier parti de
France se doit
aujourd'hui d'être en interactivité avec
avec les les adhérant et bien au-delà et
franchement je peux dire que ça
fonctionne cet après-midi avec Éric on
anim anera un atelier avec les
secrétaires départementaux donc de de
toute la France on leur présentera cette
plateforme de contribution l'idée est
que le débat aille ne reste pas qu'à
Paris là c'est la députée de province
qui le dit breton mais que les débat ils
aillent aussi au plus près des
adhérentss les républicains et du
terrain donc moi j'encourage fort
fortement les secrétaires départementaux
les présidents de nos fédérations à
organiser et à relayer ces débats moi
j'ai commencer à le faire dans mon
département d'il les Villain ça
fonctionne très bien et les gens sont
particulièrement
preneurs un potentiel extraordinaire
enfin c'est la première fois qu'un
projet est aussi contributif c'est on
laisse la possibilité aux uns et aux
autres aux Français au fond de
participer aux militants après de de
voter à l'intérieur de des républicains
c'est normal celui qui vote et celui qui
a une carte d'adhésion mais celui qui
qui produit celui qui qui propose est au
fond un Français qui n'est pas
nécessairement adhérant des républicains
donc c'est extrêmement important d'avoir
cette cette capacité on va essayer de la
développer au maximum c'est sans doute
la première fois qu'un projet sur un
parti politique utilise autant ces
moyens de communication mais au fond
également le mettre au cœur de nos de
nos
préoccupations j'ai dis les journalistes
sont des citoyens ils peuvent tout à
fait
contribuer tous les Français qui le
souhaitent mais il y a de la modération
vous avez
entendu alors dans le travail de
délitement de l'autorité de
l'État mise en œuvre par François
Hollande et le gouvernement
euh ce travail crée des mécontents qui
s'ajoutent les uns aux autres de de
semaine en semaine et nous pourrions
créer une rubrique à l'occasion de cette
conférence de presse hebdomadaire avec
les mécontent du moment la semaine
dernière nous vous avons parlé du
mouvement des médecins contre la loi
Touren cette semaine
euh deux deux types de manifestation il
y a d'abord la manifestation des
policiers qui que nous soutenons
d'ailleurs qui est un véritable désaveux
pour la politique pénale de Madame
tobira
euh les policiers sont victimes du
désarmement pénal qui est mis en place
par Madame tobira je vous rappelle que
un policier lutte toujours contre la
mort suite à l'odieuse agression dont il
a fait l'objet
par un détenu qui était en permission de
sortie
euh Nicolas Sarkozi d'ailleurs recevra
mercredi les syndicats de de
police sur sur ces sujets et nous aurons
le 3 novembre une journée de travail sur
la sécurité il y a une impérieuse
nécessité que nous faisions des que nous
fassions pardon des des
propositions pour rétablir l'autorité de
l'État en matière de sécurité et en
matière de justice et j'ai nous avons pu
entendre madame toira se se réfugier
derrière le principe de euh
l'indépendance des magistrats mais euh
c'est le fruit de la politique pénale
qu'elle mène cette malheureuse affaire
euh quant à longueur de discours on dit
qu'il faut éviter les peines de prison
pour les délinquants quand on veut
mettre fin à la rétention de sûreté pour
les délinquants dangereux quand on veut
supprimer les peines planché pour les
récidivistes quand on veut supprimer les
tribunaux correctionnels pour mineurs
euh il faut pas s'étonner que euh des
délinquants violents soient remis en
liberté et donc euh malheureusement
cette affaire comme d'autres est le
fruit du véritable désarmement pénal mis
en place par Madame
toubira alors autre sujet de de colère
mais qui n'est que représentatif
finalement de de la politique que mène
le le gouvernement qui est euh de ne pas
voir et de ne pas entendre la la
détresse des Français euh ce weekend il
y a eu la manifestation euh des
enseignants euh la réforme du collège
est une réforme qui est rejetée de
manière massive que ce soit par les
parents ou le corps enseignant euh Najad
Valo Belkassem se refuse d'entendre
toute critique et estime que cette
réforme est une réussite or même des
syndicats de gauche se sont mobilisés
contre contre cette réforme il y a une
véritable il y a un véritable rejet de
cette réforme du collège qui s'enracine
profondément que ce soit chez les
parents mais également chez le corps
enseignant comme je vous le disais la
politique éducative du gouvernement est
rejetée elle a été avec la réforme des
rythmes scolaires elle est avec la
réforme du collège et c'est vrai que
François Hollande il y a quelques jours
nous disait que la rentrée scolaire
avait été une réussite il s'est
lourdement trompé puisque la
mobilisation est est toujours là et il
refuse d'admettre ce ce rejet euh
aujourd'hui il est urgent d'entendre la
colère des professeurs et la colère des
parents face à ce à cette réforme qui
est absolument dangereuse pour pour
l'éducation de nos enfants et et je
crois qu'il faut revenir sur les
différentes euh sur les différents
dispositifs de de de cette réforme que
ce soit les langues les classes bilang
le latin le grec ou ce qu'ils appellent
les EP il faut revenir et entendre les
propositions qui sont fait par le corps
enseignant ou par de grands
intellectuels que la ministre préfère
appeler des pseudos intellectuel donc
nous sommes du côté des des parents et
et des enseignants qui veulent que leur
parole soi entendu par par la ministre
car il en va de l'avenir de l'éducation
nationale et de l'avenir de nos enfants
alors autre sujet Sébastien va évoquer
la fiscalité oui de la même manière que
nous pourrions faire un un point chaque
semaine sur les mécontents du moment euh
nous pouvons faire chaque semaine un
point sur cacophonie et attermoimement
de la majorité cette semaine Eric vert
l'a évoqué euh la cacophonie vient de
laffronte qui est menée par un député
mais pas le moindre c'est Jean-Marc
hraud qui mène une fronde sur la
fiscalité où il
a fait une proposition qui est cignée
par 130 députés socialistes et la
question que nous nous posons c'est qui
va gagner le Premier Ministre en charge
actuel euh ou son prédécesseur qui fait
partie de la même majorité c'est
d'ailleurs la première fois qu'il y a un
tel affrontement entre un un Premier
Ministre en poste et son prédécesseur
euh immédiat euh qui est du même bord et
donc il faut que le gouvernement nous
dise si oui ou non il nous prépare une
fusion de l'impôt sur le revenu et de la
CSG les Français on doit de savoir
et la question qu'on peut se poser
finalement et c'est peut-être un message
pour Monsieur
cambadellis c'est que il va peut-être
falloir qu'il prépare un second
référendum pour savoir quelle doit être
la ligne du gouvernement en matière de
fiscalité et donc puisque les
socialistes n'arrivent pas à se mettre
d'accord entre eux et bien monsieur
cambadellist va peut-être devoir prendre
une deuxième fois sa crécelle et son
urne pour aller sur les marchés et
demander au peuple de gauche comme ils
disent euh leur avis sur la ligne qui
doit être tenue par le gouvernement en
matière de
fiscalité merci Sébastien tu m'offre une
bonne
transition effectivement Jean Christophe
Camba
d'éiss fin septembre espérer plus de
300000 votants pour sa consultation et
aujourd'hui il en est à peu près à
200000 il espère 200000 votants et
200000 votants ce serait un succès pour
cette consultation pour pour arriver à
l'unité à gauche dès le premier tour des
régionales à défaut de convaincre par
par les arguments par leur politique qui
par une politique cohérente
Jean-Christophe cambadelli en arrive à
faire à mettre des NES dans les marchés
euh pour pour pour pour avoir un appui
euh pour pour créer l'unité de la gauche
dès le premier tour alors il a quand
même des questions à se poser eux qui
sont si promptes à demander un contrôle
systématique de chaque consultation
menée par les républicain vont mettre
donc sur les marchés de France des urnes
et demander des votes mais quel quel va
être le contrôle de ces votes quel va
être le contrôle des résultats de ces de
cette consultation nous chez les
républicains nous sommes dans la
transparence systématiquement il y a un
usuciier qui vient lors de chacune des
consultations nous avons également fait
appel à unuciier pour euh ce qui est du
nombre d'adhérents nous aimerions que le
Parti socialiste fasse euh preuve
d'autant de rigueur et d'autant de
transparence sur cette consultation donc
nous l'attendons sur sur ce point
précisément